Розбиті вікна та двері,
десятки постраждалих протестувальників та правоохоронців.
Це наслідки недільної акції у центрі Києва "Руху нових сил".
Ініціатором ходи до будівлі був сам лідер руху Міхеіл Саакашвілі.
"Ми зараз звідси ідемо в палац Жовтневий,
і в Жовтневому палаці буде штаб
штаб нашої координаційної ради."
Щоправда, через кілька годин після цієї заяви він відхрестився від штурму,
поклавши провину на провокаторів.
Відмежувалися від дій учасників акції і його недавні соратники.
Зокрема, Єгор Соболєв написав у Фейсбуку:
"перш ніж закликати людей зі сцени, треба думати, куди їх кличеш".
Засудили силові дії і інші однодумці з парламенту -
Сергій Лещенко та Мустафа Наєм.
Мовляв, це підриває довіру до акцій протесту
та може відштовхнути людей.
"Із тих громадських рухів,
політичних сил, які виходили разом із Саакашвілі у жовтні,  зараз не лишилося нікого.
Практично нікого."
Політолог Володимир Фесенко вважає, що у випадку з Жовтневим
мирний протест вийшов з-під контролю.
Через цей інцидент табір опозиціонера Саакашвілі, на його думку,  ризикує розпастися.
Особливо якщо влада не виконає висунутих Саакашвілі вимог.
З огляду на відкриті щодо нього кримінальні справи, влада на поступки не піде.
"Йому потрібен швидкий успіх, конкретні результати.
Якщо не буде конкретних результатів, а будуть просто недільні акції, без результату,
це, безумовно, буде викликати розчарування навіть в учасників акцій.
По-друге, може наростати внутрішнє протиріччя
між прихильниками поміркованих дій,
такого мирного тиску на владу,
і тими, хто хоче негайно скинути Порошенка, скинути владу, провести революцію."
Дії Саакашвілі та його прихильників часто були хаотичними та непродуманими,
зазначають оглядачі.
Однак дотепер вони не переходили межу та не доводили справу до насильства.